غابه لتسعه ايام ثم عاد ليقول كنت بحاجه
للراحه النفسيه هذه الحكايه ليست حكايه
خياليه لكنها حدثت بالفعل مشاهدينا مع
لاعب نادي انبياء المصري
الذي خرج من لقاء فريقه ضد اسوان قبل
نهايه اللقاء
ليختفي بشكل مقلق قبل ان يظهر كما قال
اداره نادي مخبرا اياه
مخبرا اداره النادي بانه يعاني من ازمه
نفسيه ازمه تشاوري تعيد للادهان صراع
العديد من نجوم الرياضه العالميين مع
الاكتئاب والضغوطات النفسيه والتي تزيد مع
انتقالهم الى انديه عديده ومع احترافهم
خارج بلادهم وعدم قدرتهم على التاقلم ايضا
فان مشاكل الحياه اضافه لضغوط الجماهير قد
تؤدي باللاعبين لمتلازمه الاحتراق النفسي
تلك المتلازمه التي قد تصل ببعضهم الى حد
الانتحار او التشرد بعيدا عن الرياضه
وكذلك الملاعب
العديد مشاهدينا من اللاعبين عانوا من
الاكتئاب والازمات النفسيه يعادل سواء
خلال ممارستهم لكره القدم او حتى بعد
اعتزالهم النجم الايطاليا روبرتو بارجو
احد ابرز اللاعبين الذين عانوا من
الاكتئاب خلال ممارسته لكره القدم بسبب
اضاعته ركله الجزاء الشهيره ضد البرازيل
في نهائي مونديال عام
1994 طبعا اصيب باضطرابات يوميه قبل النوم
ولم تنتهي معاناته الا مع الاعتزال
والابتعاد النهائي عن كره القدم هناك ايضا
لاعبين اخرين
نجم منتخب انجلترا في الثمانينيات
وتسعينيات القرن الماضي عان هو الاخر من
الاكتئاب وادمان الكحول بعد اعتزال للكره
بسبب ابتعاد عن الاضواء ورغبه في الانتحار
بعد انفصال عن زوجه بسبب سوء معاملته لهذه
الزوجه وكان الانتحار للاسف حلا لدى بعض
نجوم الرياضه ابرزهم الحارس الالم
اني الذي انها حيات
ه بسبب تسببه بخساره فريقه برشلونه
والهجوم الكبير عليه من قبل الجمهور ايضا
الحال بالنسبه لنجم المنتخب الويلزي جاريث
بيلد الذي قرر انهاء حياه في العام 2011
بعد ان وصل لمراحل المتقدمه من الاكتئاب
لم تنفع معها اي اساليب علاجيه ايضا تغيرت
حياه النجم البرازيلي ادريانو لاعب انتر
ميلان ومنتخب البرازيل السابق عقب وفاه
والده المفاجئه ليضمن المخدرات ويصبح
مجردا في شوارع البرازيل بعد سنوات للاسف
تخيلوا من التالق
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من الاحساء علي الغريبه
الاختصاصي النفسي بنادي الاتفاق السعودي
والباحث في علم النفس عليه اهلا بك يعني
هذه ليس ليست مرتبطه فقط بكره القدم يعني
ربما
كره القدم الامريكيه لاعبين ومحترفين من
الملاكمه ايضا عانوا من الاحتراق النفسي
اليوم ما الذي يدفع اللاعب الى يعني ياخذ
اموال جيده مراتب جيد
باحتراف وغيره شو اللي يدفعه الى انه
يحترق نفسيا
اهلا وسهلا فيك استاذ عادل وفي مستمعي
قناه العربيه اشكركم على الاستضافه طبعا
في البدايه احب اوضح الاصل في الصحه
النفسيه هي السواء وليس الاضطراب وكما هو
معروف انه
الرياضيين يعني جزء من المجتمع فبالتالي
البيانات المتعلقه بمشكلات الصحه النفسيه
ايضا تندرج يندرج من ضمنها الرياضيين
لاسيما رياضيين نخبه طبعا
طبعا الصحه النفسيه جزء من صحه الرياض اذا
نظرنا بصحه التكامل البدنيه والجسدي ايضا
ايضا لا ننسى موضوع الصحه النفسيه وهي جزء
استاذ علي ممكن توصل هذه الضغوطات النفسيه
يعني راينا زي ما تحدثنا قبل قليل هناك
لاعبين وصلوا الى الانتحار حجم هذه
الضغوطات ليس فقط عندما يحترف خارج بلادهم
ويجب عليهم ان يتاقلموا على بيئه وهم صغار
السن بيكونوا عاده على بيئه جديده ولكن
اصلا ضغط اللعبه نفسها بانك
تحرز اهدافه بانك دائما تضلك محافظ على
مستوى معين وقعوا هذا على الصحه النفسيه
للاعب كيف بكون
اولا متطلبات المنافسه او اللعبه اللي
يمارسها الرياضي
ولما نتكلم عن الرياضيين النخبه احنا
نتكلم عن المستوى الاداء العالي مطالب
مطالب من هذا الرياضي العديد من الانجازات
في كل منافسه يجب ان يكون مستواه مستمر
ومتصل ومتوازن لا ننسى انه المطالبات
الجمهور
اثناء اثناء سلوك التنافس وايضا ما بعد
نعم بعد
انتهاء المنافسه الرياضي يرغب في ان يعيش
حياتها الاجتماعيه وقت ما يروح للاسواق
مثلا في المجمعات التجاريه يواجه يواجه
جمهور متعصب او جمهور يطالبه باداء افضل
طب علي ما هو ياخذ راتب عالي لانه محترف
وبالتالي المفترض انه متكيف مع هذه الامور
ومتعود عليها ولا لا مفترض
المتكيف عليها ولكن اذا كان الرياضي من
خلال حياته الرياضيه ما تدرب على المهارات
النفسيه يعني لم يتم تدريب هذا دوركم يعني
حضرتك
والطاقم
المرافق صحيح والله مع الاسف تواجد
الاخصائيين الرياضيين في المؤسسات
الرياضيه يبدو انه نادر
في الوطن العربي بالتحديد يعني
قليل يعني
ولكن عالميا هذا الشيء الان الانديه
الكبيره تركز عليه الصحه النفسيه يعني
تضاهي الصحه البدنيه بالاهميه بالنسبه لهم
يعني خلونا نبدا من الاكشن بلان اللي
عملته وزاره الرياضه البريطانيه في عام
السبب انه يعني سبب تركيز الانديه
الاوروبيه على الصحه النفسيه ان هناك
حالات من الرياضيين بدا عندهم ميول
انتحاريه او انهم تم تنويمهم في
المستشفيات الصحه النفسيه ابرز لاعب ارو
نا وبعد ذلك داني روز
ممكن نصرح فيها في 2018
وبالتالي
وزيره الرياضه في بريطانيا اعلنت خطه من
عام 2018 حتى عام 2024 يعني نهايه السنه
نهايه السنه القادمه الخطه هذه مفترض انها
الانديه العربيه اللي اصبحت الان يعني على
مستوى متقدم ايضا بشكل كبير انها ايضا
تنتبه لهذا الموضوع موضوع الصحه النفسيه
للاعبين
الخطه المذكوره في وزاره الرياض
البريطانيه لا تقتصر على تدريب الرياضيين
فقط بل تدريب المدربين تدريب وتدريب ايضا
اولياء الامور للاعبين اللي في فئات
العمريه طيب
بالتالي بالتالي يعني
لو راجع غضايا الصحه
النفسيه العلميه المنتشره علي ركزت على
ركزت على عدد من المحدثات بشكل سريع انه
العمر مثلا ترتبط مشكلات الصحه النفسيه
غالبا في الفئه العمريه واللاعبين اللي
يعتزلوا اللعبه طيب بالنسبه للجنس
اللاعبات اكثر افصاحه وتعبير عن مشكلات
الاكتئاب اكثر من الذكور طبعا
احنا قلنا اللاعبين المصابين ما نركز فقط
على الاصابه العضليه ايضا اثار الاصابه
على الرياضي طبعا المشكلات اللي بين شخصيه
اللي تكون بين الرياضي والمدرب او الرياضي
وزوجته مثلا او حتى الرياضه والرياضي
زميله نعم الرياضي تؤدي كثيرا بالانسحاب
من اللعبه في بعض
القضايا الاجتماعيه
الاخرى ابرز لاعب
نادي انتر ميلانو ايطالي اعان كثيرا من
الجمهور في في ميلان يعني علي علي يعني
ايضا يمكن المذيعين يتعرضون الى هذا
الاحتراق النفسي لان المنتجه البرنامج
قاعد تحرقني نفسيا تضغط علي اني فاعتذر
على الغريب الاختصاص النفسي من نادي
الاتفاق السعودي شكرا جزيلا لك يعطيك
العافيه وعلى كل هذه المعلومات
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات